brian we hear filmmakers say that
filmmaking keeps them out of trouble
or they say you know this is all i can
do this is why i do it
even though it's hard at times sometimes
i wonder is it really all they can do or
that's just what they sort of say
to themselves that's what they want to
do what are your thoughts on this
i'm sure it varies for each filmmaker i
mean for me
i can do other things but what i find
happens is if i don't
do something creative and for me my
creativity
seems to always go visual so it always
goes into movies
if a certain amount of time passes and i
haven't done something i start to go a
little crazy a little stir crazy
so there's like this drive to for me
it's a drive to tell stories
and then eventually i write a lot and i
write a lot of stories
and usually the story we end up doing
with my filmmaking partner low
is usually one that i've had for a while
that i keep coming back to or won't go
away
like you won't sometimes i'll be able to
write something and it's kind of done
even though it's like never seen the
light of day maybe it's a script or
a story or just an idea i can get it out
of my system
and it feels like okay i'm okay but
every now and then there's a story that
i just keep i keep thinking about it it
comes back and comes back and comes back
and usually that's the one who's like i
have to do this one you know find a way
to
make it in a format that other people
can see it you know
is there sort of a time frame for you
like if you're in between projects
is there like a three-month window where
if you don't have something new to work
on
you can start to feel yourself slipping
so to speak
uh i mean i'm always like thinking of
ideas
um so it's like it stays longer than a
three-month window for me as long as i
as long as i'm like collecting my ideas
and thinking about stories and writing
it down i'm fine i think it's like
if if it's like going up to a year and
i'm not
actively involved in making a movie or
making some other creative project
which will come to fruition so other
people can see it then i probably get
get the shakes almost like i have to do
it you know i have to do something
yeah what do you start to see yourself
slipping into when you know
like do you become bored easily or how
do you know like oh you know what this
is after a while you learn
this is because i need to start working
on something you know for me it's it's
like
really i just kind of get into malaise
it's like is it really it's like doing
something creative is kind of what makes
me feel alive
and if too much time goes by and i'm not
doing something creative
it's just i don't know i find myself
kind of sinking into this like
malaise of just life isn't really
working for me and then i'm like what's
wrong and i'm like and then it kind of
hits me like oh because i'm not doing
something creative
yeah so amazingly i forget every time
they're like why am i feeling this way
and then it's like oh that's because i'm
not
creatively involved in something uh
fortunately i have a lot of other things
that i do
which are also creative so it helps me
kind of sustain it a little bit but
for me it's like the projects i'm most
passionate about
are the ones that my wife and filmmaking
partner laurence lowe
that we do together and those are the
ones because it's our project and
it's a passion project so we kind of
control it from beginning middle and
end so it's very much like our vision of
what we want to tell
and that is to me the most creatively
satisfying is when you can do a project
like that
where it's not going to have too much
outside influence that changes what
you're trying to make
what other creative things do you do i
do editing
so i do editing for a television series
television shows
which obviously involves a lot of
creativity i do a lot of like
uh docu reality type shows
which actually requires you as an editor
to be very involved in story
because you're working with the story
people and the producers to help figure
out the story
and develop so it's like it's more than
just cutting something from a script
it's very it really engages you
creatively because you're really working
on
figuring out like well how do we tell
the story what is the story
sometimes you're figuring out well you
know what is this you know what is the
story and how do you tell a beginning
middle and end
and make it dramatic and and keep people
engaged with it
yeah i heard an author speak this
weekend a brazilian author and forgive
me on her name i'll put it at the below
the line part of the video
but she said that when she gets writer's
block and she says it's very real
that she has to do things like go to
museums
just just you know other creative things
that are not writing
do you ever feel blocked and if so do
you have a ways to get out of it
well i definitely feel like uh going
places
like lo and i like taking trips and
going places we like to go out to the
desert
or to the mountains sometimes up to the
beach or the ocean
it's like i get a lot of inspiration
from locations
especially on uh with movies uh and it
gets a little tricky sometimes because
sometimes i i fall so in love with the
location it's hard for me to imagine not
shooting it there
but uh but they'll be usually a location
could be a really big inspiration for me
like i'll
see something and then it starts my mind
going what if what if what if
and uh there's been places that we've
incorporated uh
in our films um sometimes it's not that
exact same location
but like an idea from that location will
find its way into the story
something inspired by so i i find like
the
best way for me at least creatively is
to find the inspiration from real life
uh because if you don't do that then i
feel like you get into a cycle of
copying
which is really easy to fall into it
it's really easy to look at a movie
and go oh i like that movie but i would
have done something like this with that
movie and then you know you can easily
change it a few degrees and
it'd be a new movie but in essence it's
going to be
so built on the other film that it's not
really a new thing
whereas if you can get the inspiration
from life or or stories you hear from
other people like real stories that
happen to them
or uh they know of a friend something
happened a lot of times that can spark
the imagination
and think like oh well you know what if
what if that story happened and then
this happened and that happened
to me that's that's the most fun it's
kind of like taking that inspiration
from real life
is location never a character and then
if you're filming i know
for sure yes i would say location
uh for us is almost always uh a
character
in almost every film we've done
i think it's funny because uh this this
film um
dark remains i forget this is the polish
version
oh okay this is dark remains uh
a location that uh laurence lowe found
as i was writing the script
she fell in love with this like prison
location that was in
rome georgia which is no longer in
existence but it was a closed prison
uh but they we could actually go there
and shoot and she's like well you have
to add
a prison to the story because this
prison's so great i'm like well there's
no way to put a prison in the store
but anyway after like complaining for a
while i woke up the next day and i'm
like oh
well if this prison became part of the
story like this it changed everything
and it made it better
i mean it rippled through and the prison
became such a thing like when it came
out in japan they're like
they they retitled a ghost prison
and like you know none of these things
are in the movie but it's not even the
prison that's in the movie
and but they like to do this with
clipart and chains the graphics when it
goes overseas but they decided they
loved the prison so much the movie title
became ghost prison
so definitely like locations become like
a huge thing
uh this film uh which was our second
film goes to the needle which they read
titled asphyxia
i think in spain uh that one factor a
factory is a very key location for the
main character
and a lot of events take place in the
factory and that became like a very
key part to the film and once we found
the factory
we did a lot of revisions on the script
in writing
because the the location inspired us
because they had other things in the
script but once you see the real factor
you're like oh well this could happen
and this could happen and this is
there was an elevator there there's this
amazing freight elevator that was there
and that
added like this whole thing with going
between the different floors and
and so like for me it's like locations
including
the first foam we did uh freezer
uh was our first film and this actually
took place on what was
uh the family farm that i spent a lot of
time on growing up
i was in virginia right across the
border from tennessee
and uh and i spent a lot of childhood
years and weekends and weeks on this
farm and that location was like
it basically was the script because i
basically once i came up with the story
and realized it was happening here it
like you would go with the characters
here and the characters and the
situations what would happen
because there are these things in that
location so once you bring in your
protagonists your antagonists
and you go well what would they do and
then based
on being in this environment and then
you basically get scenes and you get
moments and it actually
influences the writing of the script and
i find that i don't know i find it very
exciting
uh when your location can actually be
the the
when the location that inspires the
story can actually be the one that you
shoot at
that's the best uh i mean it doesn't
always work out because you maybe can't
for practical reasons she did that
location um but that's the best case
scenario
otherwise whenever you do get the real
location you you kind of have to embrace
it and make changes
instead of trying to fight it to be the
location you don't have because that'll
work against you
but location definitely a character yeah
well you've brought several dvds here
and they all have amazing covers
you were telling us off-camera that some
of them are actually the same films
right but then during is it the
distribution phase then they change
titles and covers
yes okay well basically what happens is
uh when you get your foreign sales agent
or foreign distributor
who basically sells it to the other
countries they get all the artwork
uh that you have to redo whatever cover
they want and they can retitle it to
whatever title they want and lots of
times they'll add their own
artwork like for example this film
is dark remains uh this was kind of
similar to the american cover
uh but they they changed it a little bit
and then in
in canada and canada yeah i think it's
possible
in canada um they really change it they
say well okay we want a blue
want a blue look and it it's unrated
which is funny because
it's the same version as the radiant
version but i guess they didn't re-rate
it in canada
so is the underrated version so that was
their take on it but still using the
same
basic poster art but then when it got to
japan they really loved the prison that
was in the film so they decided to go
with ghost prison
and they added a prison that actually
isn't the president of the movie and
then they used
this person from clip art who's not in
the movie at all
but there is a ghost kind of like her in
the movie
but they decided they wanted this look
for the asian markets as more of an
asian actress so
they went that way so it just it changed
and of course
i'll actually love this one a lot
australia they decided to focus
on this there's a ghost girl character
in the movie and they decided to like
make the focus more on her
so they totally changed the art and put
the other ghosts kind of around her but
that was a really i thought creative
you know but it's all the same movie so
it's kind of it's kind of funny then you
know sometimes they'll change the title
like
ghost of the needle became uh
in spain it became asphyxia and what's
funny is they actually got to use that
was supposed to be the cover
in the u.s for the movie but they um
they decided they couldn't use it
because they had to get it rated back
then
and the ratings board would not allow
this image to be used
for an r rating and we had to deliver an
r rating or the other distributor wanted
us to
so um so i actually got our original
artwork
to change the title of sticks here but i
love this title it's a great title
and in other countries it was called
dead still so it just it just
changes depending on what they think
they can sell in that uh
in that marketplace and that's so that's
five different versions
of the same movie pretty well well the
two different ones there's dark remains
oh this one was ghost of the needle and
then
this other one which i did bring was
called uh
freezer most of the countries called it
freezer with apostrophe er
because it's freeze her and they
this image kind of stayed the same in
most of the countries but
in the us it got released differently
they decided to call it
cold blood because they thought they
were worried that freezer
sounded too comedic because it was like
they're afraid that freeze
hyphen er would make it feel more like a
it's a black comedy but it's a very
subtle dark
comedy so i think that's one of the
reasons they wanted to change it
so um so yeah and then
this cover changed we had a totally
different
vod cover and then the dvd they wanted
to make it look more like a
slasher-risk i guess because they put
some blood in and an environment that's
not in the movie and
clip art in the back which doesn't
really represent the movie well and
that's one of the challenges
is you know distributors are always like
well we want to
have an image that makes people get the
movie but
the trick of it is you also you want
your image to grab people
so it's good to get other people's
advice on what can market and sell the
movie
but what's important is you want the
image to attract the people who are
going to like
the movie because you want to be able to
sell what you're really selling
and trouble can write you what you can
run into with the cover is
they can make a cover where they're
selling to a different sub-genre of
horror
and maybe those sub-genre fans won't be
happy with the movie because it's a
different movie but the people who
really like that movie and then a
different sub-genre for
won't check it out because of the cover
so you kind of can get yourself in this
in this like trap so uh it's tricky when
dealing with distributors you always
want to get one that will
work with you in terms of the cover art
or at least involve you in it
but it's very difficult of course for
you to ever get final
say on it but it's always good to try to
make it part of the process that you can
be involved in it
uh so you can try to keep it on track to
what you think
represents the movie for what it is
forgive me what are the different sub
genres of of horror because it's
interesting like your movie could be
divided into different sub genres just
depending on how they want to market it
well as the marketing divides into
different scenarios uh but basically
it's like you know there's like
you know the slasher movies uh you know
you get slasher movies
you get uh you know creature films
uh you can get more science fiction
films
uh in the horror genre i mean like
malignant was medical horror
so it was like a medical horror subgenre
you have supernatural
subgenre and within the supernatural you
can have supernatural like possession
exorcist
or you could have ghosts so it's like
there's basically all these different
little subgenres in horror and lots of
times
they'll mix like our our last film um
that uh is on the festival circuit right
now echoes
echoes of fear um
it's a movie it's a supernatural horror
movie supernatural horror ghost movie
um but it takes an interesting turn it
still saves the supernatural ghost movie
but it takes an interesting term if you
don't
talk about because you don't want to
ruin the movie sure but but it
but it's an example of how the draw some
different sub genres can mix within the
same film
uh and that can be really exciting well
i think when when as an audience
that's what i like as an audience person
is i love to be able to go into a movie
i like to go in cold i i like when i go
to see a movie it's like
if i know i'm gonna see it it's like i
will not watch the trailer
i i just try to avoid reading anything
about it especially reviews because they
tend to give you a giant plot synopsis
uh i like i like if i know i'm gonna see
a movie like oh i wanna see that movie i
like i try to like know nothing about it
and then go see it and then because that
way i like to be surprised
uh and then after that i'll read the
reviews and and look at the
trailer and that kind of stuff but i
like to go in cold i'm the same way and
i like
it it's fun and i love it when there's a
movie that you you think it's going one
way and then it goes into another
it's like to me really exciting uh and
horror when you when you can't quite
figure out what
you know it's fun that way you know
because because it's like evolves and it
has the twists and turns and it's just
organic and it's
it's just a lot of fun and a lot of
marketing now
i get it they want to sell the movie but
lots of times to sell the movie they
like kind of blow everything
and maybe that'll make someone rent and
watch the movie but it's really going to
diminish their experience because
they'll take stuff in the third act
and uh for me i'm a very visual person
so when i watch a trailer like that
i remember those images so it will
affect me as i'm watching the movie
because i know in the back of my brain
things are coming because i haven't seen
it yet
from the trailer maybe other people can
watch the trailer kind of blank
after seeing it and not have it ruined
for them but
you know so the trailer for our last
film echoes the fear it was a real
challenge for me
was to do a trailer which has the mood
in the atmosphere and tells you it's a
suspenseful scary movie
but at the same time it shows good
images in there but the same time
doesn't
blow the movie so you can still have the
experience where those
where that suspense and scarce and stuff
will work when you see the movie the
trailer hasn't ruined it that was a big
challenge i think i ended up doing like
six or seven drafts of the trailer
working with
uh uh i worked with the sales agent
foreign distributor on it as well
getting some notes i got notes from
other people as well i mean i kept
getting notes
and people felt like what could help
market the movie and then i had to
figure out a way to kind of like do
those notes without ruining
uh giving anything away and ruining it
so it was a challenge
it's a challenge can you think of some
current films because like
let's say hereditary i didn't know too
much about it going in
and i was pleasantly surprised by the
twists and turns and i wouldn't say i'm
like a total horror like you know
fanatic right but i really i was really
impressed with that can you think of
other films where
it really takes you on a ride where
you're not expecting stuff oh gosh
so often in horror uh so good about that
trying to think oh gosh even carried i
mean
i use those two examples probably too
much so i've got to stop but well no no
gary's great
see that's a great example i mean it's
hard to remember now because
you know the marketing turned into like
her soaked in the blood
right on the stage but initially you
know everyone
of course that also came from the book
so in a way they
they assumed that a lot of people
already knew the basic just the story
because of the stephen king book
so i think they probably weren't too
worried about ruining it um
shoot i was just thinking about an
example of one and then i lost it well
the exorcist
too because you're not really totally
sure
you hope that she's going to be cured
right right
but you don't know and the doctor the
he becomes increasingly more and more
angry
right you know and kind of becomes his
own monster you know
right well that's like that's like it's
funny like both of
such a challenge when they're based on a
book because then you're dealing with
the expectation that everyone wants it
to follow the book
but then you have to it's a movie so you
have to adapt it you can't
just do the book because usually in a
book especially stephen king book
you know so much is internal with what's
inside the characters heads
which you can't really get you have to
kind of like i mean a great example
is the shining which is an amazing book
by stephen king
and it's an amazing movie by stanley
kruber they're very
very very different but they're both
amazing i mean kubrick basically took
the essence
of what was in king's book and said well
how can i tell this visually in a movie
that will work
and you know i think king got really mad
because a lot of things were dropped
and a lot of things unless you've read
the book you wouldn't even understand
when watching the movie
but cooper knew like it had to be its
own thing you know instead of the hedge
monsters you have the maze
the hedge maze because he knew that the
hedge monsters was great in the book
but especially at that time with the
special effects it would it
could be really cheesy and and just you
know
not work and become a laughable thing so
he kind of made that
same scary environment but making the
hotel a character but doing it visually
with the camera and like the great shot
following behind the kid on the big
like riding through the hallway of the
thing so
uh and i was trying to think of vic your
uh your first question about
movies that surprised you when you
watched it like my brain is just
out of nerves it's just defaulting back
to like the early movies i saw when i
was
was younger like john carpenter's the
thing i knew nothing about that
when i when i watched it and that's and
it's so different from the original
movie version and and so different from
the short story
that you just had no idea going into
that movie what was going to happen
and i'm assuming it's not a spoiler now
because everyone's seen this movie but
but like when you're watching the movie
and you have this dog and you're like oh
my gosh don't shoot the dog who are
these
crazy people in the helicopter shooting
this
shooting at this poor dog and of course
you realize later
like the people the helicopter know what
that dog is and it's not a dog and it's
the alien it's the creature
but when you're first watching it and
having that experience you don't know
that
so it's like it's it's it's so great
because it it like tricks your
sympathies
without because it's like you don't know
what's going to happen and that's a
great movie where you like
you never know who the creature is and
who's the person who actually is the
alien
so that constantly changes and evolves
and you don't know where it's going it's
such a
effective film with environment as well
with the location and like people forget
because everyone knows now norman bates
is the killer in psycho
but when cycle came out people did not
know that
so people thought that there was this
guy with this crazy murdering mother
doing this and that's why original
people watching psycho believe
and you know hitchcock made this whole
thing like please don't ruin the ending
it's the only ending i have
or something like that i'm paraphrasing
but that was part of the marketing it
was like don't blow the ending
and so for people to have that
experience and not know
it's like unfortunately like by time i
saw psycho it was so known that norman
bates is the killer
that you don't get that experience
anymore but to be i imagine to be in the
theater and have that experience of
watching psycho not knowing
that norman bates is the killer and you
have such sympathy for him because he's
this poor hindsight
boy so that's a great example
like you know and i don't know it's like
how hard would it be now to try to put
out a movie
like psycho for the first time and not
have it be ruined
you know not have it be spoiled and
ruined it'd be it's be so difficult now
with social media and everything
it's just very difficult basically
people basically people have to bang
it's like please don't you know like the
filmmakers basically say like please
don't ruin the ending you know
and then everyone rushes to the theater
sometimes to see it the first weekend
because they know it's going to be
ruined
because once it comes out like
everyone's going to start blathering
about it and writing articles and
they'll be spoilers now and headlines
like i won't read
the article because i don't want to ruin
the movie but then they'll they'll blow
it in the headline you're like what are
you doing
so it's like just by seeing the headline
it's kind of ruining something from the
film
or on twitter yeah twitter it's like
it's it's very it's very frustrating
i think to be able to go into uh a movie
night
cold is very difficult i think you have
to actively work on it now
would you be a filmmaker today if you
didn't go to usc oh yeah
i i was like making movies like way
before usc i mean i started
i started doing movies when i was 10
years old
my dad worked uh at magnavox
and he brought home like an old video
camera where it's like this huge video
camera with a tethered cord and a
separate deck
uh so actually the first thing i did
when i was 10 years old
was i adapted something a house of
frankenstein
i i use that title but i adapted like
something that someone else had written
and adapted it and with my friends we
did this thing i played dr jekyll mr
hyde
but someone else played frankenstein
someone played the wolf man but we
actually did a house of frankenstein
uh and that was the first thing i did
when i was 10 years old and then i got
into doing super 8 films
and uh cutting super 8 films and that
kind of stuff and
so i've been doing that since i was 10.
so i kind of
always knew from that point on i i
wanted to
because it started out i wanted to tell
stories and the problem is i would write
these plays but the plays were really
elaborate
it would require the audience to like
run around in the woods with my friends
to follow the play
which i guess would be kind of cool now
but at the time it wasn't very practical
so that's how i kind of got into
filmmaking was i wanted to be able to
tell the story and it was it was not
practical
to bring the audience to us i need to
figure out a way to tell the story and
bring it to them
and that's how i got into doing movies
and once i started doing it
and realizing like oh my gosh look what
you can do you know you can do time
compression you can do
all these things you can't do in a play
uh and then it became really exciting as
a kid
basically your imagination just goes and
all those little
shorts are ridiculous of course because
your kids running around making it but
it was a great way to learn
uh and because there was no youtube
back then say none of those things were
seen so so nothing
doesn't embarrass me because it doesn't
exist in a way anyone can see it but
i i always knew from that point on that
i wanted to make
movies and i was always into horror and
science fiction
and thriller and those sub-genres always
kind of
merged oftentimes like they would kind
of like blend together
i would be like a science fiction horror
or horror sci-fi or
you know if it was thriller would be
like big horror elements in it
and so it kind of just gravitated and
grew into that
and our first film i did with my wife
laurence my first feature
uh was a horror film psychological
horror film
and we really enjoyed it and it kind of
like led into our next horror film and
they've all been kind of different
subgenres we
gravitate most i would say to
supernatural
uh our our uh our first two were kind of
like psychological
slash supernatural so it's almost like
the first one was 100 psychological
but there were supernatural occurrences
because it was happening in his head
the second one was much more ghosts of
the needle was much more like
is it in his head or is it out there and
then our third film we did was a
straight-up supernatural ghost
movie where we made it all it kind of
went all the way and our last one we did
echoes of fear also is a supernatural
uh ghost movie so but even within that
there's a key element to the film
talking about hauntings
and there's a debate she has with her
best friend
in terms of like well am i am i going
crazy
is it a ghost out there or am i going
crazy and seeing things and
and her friend kind of tells her it's
like well if a ghost is going to reach
you
it's going to be in your head either way
so i'm kind of like i'm very intrigued
by the idea of kind of breaking down
this
this barrier of whether it's something
in your head
versus out there in this idea that if
it's in your head it's not real
well all reality is in our head so
that's how we process the world
so it's like to me it becomes a very
artificial borderline in a lot of movies
where it's like oh
is it in her head or in her his head is
he crazy or is it out there and it's
supernatural where i think
to me it's more intriguing like the
blurred line and
in terms of what that means uh between
what's reality in the head and reality
out there when all reality is
what you process inside your head right
didn't philip k
dick also kind of wonder about that none
of them feel like you did yeah into his
own life too
oh my goodness it's dark it's a ghost
in your mind what is the purpose of
story the purpose of story
yeah like uh well why do we need story
science fiction what is the reason we
need story i i don't know it's like i
feel like
i feel like story is like something that
probably happened
i don't know probably before humans can
even speak probably story was being
gestures and being told
by drawing things in the sand or in the
ashes or pointing or gesturing
i think humans i don't know i think
there's an innate
need to tell stories i mean part of it
is to tell the
the real story of what's going on like
your story of
your life so you can communicate with
people in terms of what you need and
stuff
but then i think it really quickly goes
into just
being able to imagine
different scenarios because you kind of
have to do that to live life
you can't have to think about like if i
do this what could happen blah blah blah
and then you know it starts when your
imagination starts going and thinking
like that then you start thinking more
and more fanciful ideas
and and then you know i start making up
characters i don't know it's just like i
feel like
it's part of basic communication with
people is is like
we want to be able to read a story or
experience
a story that's different from our own
life experience we want to be exposed to
something different
than what we're seeing in our daily day
to day lives
because it just activates the brain and
just makes you think about
things in the world differently reading
a story and here and seeing other
people's viewpoints which comes from the
story whether it be fiction or
non-fiction
i think because someone else created it
or wrote it
you're being exposed to like a different
way of thinking about the world
which i think is just really important
to be able to function
in the world to be able to see things
from a different perspective i think
it's an easy trap
we can fall into when we only surround
ourselves with
stories of just what we believe or what
we think about or just relates to our
little bubble
i think it's very dangerous i think
story is very important
so we can understand how other people
live and exist in the world
and see those other viewpoints so we can
be more open-minded and understand that
like everything doesn't revolve around
our little personal lives
and all that comes from story i think
that's a great point and even more so
now because we click on an article
online and now that reality is reflected
back to us
a hundred times because now that
algorithm is going to show us
so that's why so many stuff that's what
you want to read
right and now you know they think that
that's you know you're you're
wanting to learn all about golf and so
right right it's very difficult
you're it's a that's that's a really
good example because it's harder and
harder to like because i have a lot of
interest and
i like to look at a lot of different
articles and i noticed that
like like if i click on an article about
x all of a sudden there's all these
articles about the same thing coming up
it's like no i just
kind of wanted to sample that and i'm
good
if i want to know more about it i'm
going to google it
but yeah it it is interesting how
i mean it's amazing because of the
internet
that you have all this access
information
that was so hard to get and the flip
side of it is
you're right now that there's this way
of algorithms channeling things to you
it's almost
limiting you a little bit it was felt
even like
10 years ago on the internet felt much
more wide open
like you would just go anywhere go who
knows what you'd click on and go see and
go find and
now that they're trying to target you
and guide you down a certain
path you kind of have to actively fight
it i think now
you have to be aware of it and fight it
uh and i think
it's dangerous and people don't realize
i think people are becoming more aware
of it now i hope
but it's very dangerous people don't
realize that things are being channeled
to them
because they start to believe like oh
that's what's going on in the world but
is it you know and then you kind of have
to make your list of things
if it's non-fiction for me at least it's
like i have my list of places i go to
which i feel like will be able to give
me real news i mean i remember growing
up
maybe i'm showing my age but i remember
growing up that when you basically got
news you weren't worried about i mean
there was a whole separate thing like
this is blah blah's opinion this is the
opinion moment
in the newscast or whatever and the rest
of it was news it was basically facts
and that's the way it was
and uh now it's like very
hard to find the places where you know
you get real news they're out there
uh definitely like most of the
mainstream big old news organizations
you know you can
still like trust them but there's this
so many people are getting their news
now from other little places that you're
like well where are they
you know who are these people and how
much research did they put in and
you know this is dangerous it's probably
a dangerous topic to get into
maybe the algorithm could be haunting
someone that'll be the next one it's
stalking that's actually not bad yeah
yeah that's actually that's actually not
a bad idea
it's actually a good idea
how did you break into the business well
i got started um
work-wise i got started from a writing
producing standpoint
and i started out actually
in atlanta georgia uh at a production
company and it was writing producing
shows
some of them were going on nbc they were
basically documentary specials
and tbs when they had documentary
specials
on that as well so i kind of started out
in that writing and producing
and then that kind of did more into
directing in that
uh as well but at the same time
i've always been kind of like doing my
original
story projects and then once i got
together with um
laurence my wife lo we basically
found we had very similar interests and
she came at it more from a visual dp
side
initially but as we started doing
projects together everything kind of
really blurred
together in terms of what we would do
and so we basically have been making i
mean echoes of fear is our is our fifth
uh feature film it's also our fifth
horror feature
uh that we've done together but it was
the first one that uh we co-directed
officially co-directed although i mean
because the lines had just been keep
kept blurring anyway with what we did
and eventually in this one we're like
okay you know what you're going to
officially co-direct this one
because we she already as a dp and we
were very collaborative i mean
the directing and and the work you do as
a dp it was already getting like this
and she was working with the actors it
was just happening organically
so we just basically moved it all the
way to say we're officially co-directing
so we co-directed it we work on the
story together
uh i actually write the script the
mechanics of writing the script but
she's very involved in story and and
story ideas
uh and taking the scrump once i get it
and coming up with like all these
original interesting ideas which
inherently make it a lot more
complicated which is funny because she's
also the producer
so she gives me these limitations like
okay you do it like this and then i do
it like that and then she starts
expanding the story as it becomes more
and more difficult to produce but it's
okay because she's doing it
but we basically develop the story and
and grow it from there and it's very
organic process
you went to usc but you grew up in the
south is that right
yeah oh yes i was born in new jersey but
i grew up in east tennessee oh you were
born in jersey
yeah it was very very few years
interesting that i i
really grew up uh machado was it was in
east tennessee
so a lot of uh like our first film we
did together uh freezer
a lot of that was based on a farm a
family farm
that i spent a lot of time on
growing up but definitely like for me
environment's very important
from a horror film and from growing up
in the south there was a lot of stuff in
the mountains
and trees and woods and farms and barns
and
all that kind of stuff so that was very
much in the early
beginning uh when we did our first
feature a lot of that
came into that and a lot of secrets too
if you watch um
uh sharp objects yeah if you watch it
yes
fantastic love it um the the the
secretive nature
of all the characters and them sort of
sort of revealing themselves and holding
it back so it's
something very interesting that you know
and and the you know the bless your
heart but then you can't tell well it's
very
they really mean it or not yes it's very
interesting in a small town
it's like it's weird you have to keep
your guard up so much
in a small town because it's like
everybody
excuse me everybody knows everybody and
then um
gossip gets around and everybody talks
so you
just kind of really have to keep like a
very careful
face it's like when you get into the
city which i love
it's like it's like everyone is so cool
nobody cares right it's so great
you can just be yourself and no one
really really cares anymore and to me
it's like very liberating
that you don't have to like try to be
like oh i need to be careful because
everyone's different everyone's crazy
and everyone kind of knows it in the
city
right and so it's like it's not really
that big of a deal but yeah definitely
in the small town
which is why i think a lot of great
horror movies are set in small town
environments and that
because it's like it does have that
mystery and intrigue because everyone's
always watching everyone else
you know what's the neighbor doing you
know you know what are they up to
and that kind of thing so well i think
too they don't have enough going on
in their lives in small towns and i
think a lot of bad stuff comes out of
that whether it's
real real stuff that someone's gossiping
about or
fabricated and i think you can even like
look at
the beginning of rambo you know so he's
going into this this new town and then
brian dennehy sees him you know and he's
like you know i don't recognize that
you know so there's so little going on
right that when
something that's sort of out of the
ordinary
you know what is it idol hands or the
devils
whatever that whatever that's saying
well there's a great um i can't remember
the the story but one of the original
sherlock holmes arthur corden doyle
stories that they published in the
strand he's like
in a train with watson and they're
leaving the city heading out in the
country and watson's like looking out
like oh look at the beautiful
countryside
and then sherlock holmes says well it's
an occupational hazard but i can't look
at it like that because i
i see all these neighbors and they're
all separated and they're all so
isolated i'm always like well what are
they doing
they could be doing anything because no
one's really
can see what they're doing and he goes
that's why he said like in the city
he would say in the city at least you
have your neighbors keeping you in check
because you you're you're being watched
a little bit there's people around you
but like
out in the farm in the countryside it's
like who knows what's
in the barn or in that basement or
hidden in that locked house
uh and uh it in like in the farm
uh family farmer grew up it's like my
brother-in-law stayed sometime in
in in the house before the farm got sold
and he was like it was a firm believer
like if you just
took a compass and and you drew out a
circle
that encompassed the same population
like all the stuff that's happening in
the city
is happening in the country it's all
just about the popular population but
it's scarier in the country because
it's so isolated and if something's
happening it's like how are you going to
find out about it
how did you get your first feature film
produced oh well the the first feature
film
uh produced was uh i mean once uh
i partnered up with my wife laurence and
uh
i was like working on it's funny i was
gonna do another short film
i've done a lot of short films ever
since like i was 10 years old doing
short films
so i was gonna do another short film and
uh i basically
was getting frustrated because i
couldn't really get the story i couldn't
cover the story i wanted to tell
in the short film it was it was getting
too long and then we did some tests in
super 8
and i wasn't happy with how it looked
you know is what i really need to do in
16 but
the story is too long and it would cost
too much money and 16 if you did this
short because it won't make any money
so you're going to lose all the money
you put into it and she's like washes
make it into a feature
so once he kind of like threw down the
gauntlet we started working on
on the story and fleshing it out and
figuring out and we did a lot of so many
uh script passes on that while we were
raising the money and putting the money
together and we we got a great investor
kendall dryer who had never invested in
a movie before
but he was very interested in us and was
interested in film
uh and you know we pitched in the story
and this is the story we want to tell
and he came on board as an investor
and we also invested as well with some
money and also our time
and energy to do it on sweat equity and
it took us a while it was our first film
we shot over the course of a year
i was shooting at an old family farm but
i was living in atlanta
so i was finishing my day job getting in
a car
we were driving five hours to the
location shooting all weekend
packing back up and coming back so i
could go to work on monday
so and she was working as well at a tv
station at the time
so it we basically except for two weeks
we were able to shoot
a little bit i think 14 days in a row
but the rest of it was all done
like a day and a half at a time every
week over the course of a year
so it was a long process so how does a
first-time filmmaker feature filmmaker i
realize you had shorts that you made
convinced someone who has never invested
in a movie before
to do so you know i think i think when
you're doing your
your first one if you're doing it the
way we did it was a very micro budget
way
it was just more money because back then
it's like you pretty much had to shoot
film if you wanted it to look
good at all i mean the the digital
revolution hadn't really
reached the point where it could look so
good
so we knew we wanted to shoot in 16
which of course with film stock and
processing and transfer and stuff
already
gives you a certain budget level that
you're going to have to raise money and
i think for the first one
it's like usually it comes from someone
that you know
that uh because they have to believe in
you
so you know it's hard to get someone to
believe in you if you haven't done a
feature yet even if you have shorts
so i think it's someone who believes in
you and someone who's interested in
movies as well
and they also money but they're
interested in movies and being part of
that experience
of of a movie being made
which kendall was very involved he
actually played a role in the film as
well
oh nice because we made him because he
was perfect for a role i was like you
have to be in it
uh so he put him in it but it was like a
very like uh
homegrown like tight very low
low-budgeted small
crew passion project but it turned out
really well and
we finished it and it got distributed in
the u.s but it also got distributed
overseas
around the world so it's like for a
first time film that we did on such a
micro budget it was like very
successful experience and it kind of led
into the next two kind of
pretty rapidly it kind of kept going a
little bit and then the markets and
everything changed a bit and then you
kind of had to
learn how to ride that now it's like i
think
in some ways it's easier to make a
feature film because of the
digital revolution and you can do things
now
on your home computer you can get access
to
cameras that can shoot and if you have
the right dp
and knows how to light it and then with
the right expertise it can look really
really good
uh so in that sense it's it it can bring
down the cost
but on the flip side it's much more
challenging i think in terms of
distribution in terms of distribution
where you make money
now in terms of distribution but you
just get it out there
obviously there's a million ways to do
that now but in terms of like
making it go out there where you can
make money so you can you know
get your cast and paid and your crew
paid and everything else or if you're
paying them up front by the budget so
you can get your investors money back
it's much more challenging i think now
so it's kind of an interesting
change and before it was like much more
difficult and more expensive to make the
movie but
if you could make the movie distribution
was much better now it's much
easier to maybe make the movie but
distribution is much harder so it's
kind of been the slow change
that we've seen over the course of
making the five films so it's it's
interesting
and do you think that's because sort of
the collapse of the dvd market
i think part of it is the collapse of
the dvd mark in the sense there aren't
video stores anymore
and video stores kind of was this weird
great equalizer
because your movie would be sitting on
the shelf right next to
a multi-million dollar hollywood movie
and you'd be on the same shelf in the
new releases
and if your cover was good someone might
pick it up and read the back and if the
story sounded interesting and stuff they
may rent that movie and
and check it out so it was a way of
people
finding out about your movie in the new
release section of video stores in a
very tactile way
now of course you have it in vod but
they're little tiny
little croutons and and lots of times
now
placement is based more on the
distributor and who has the muscle to
get the better placement on the
platforms and
there's all those things and that makes
it more challenging now that it's more
of a digital world as opposed to
physical media
and also actually i think it's more
challenging in terms of because of
piracy
and and the biggest reason that's the
challenge is world cells
is more difficult now because once your
movie comes out anywhere
the movie will immediately be pirated
and all those countries know that the
movie
will be pirated and it used to be there
was a very
big physical separation between the
different countries so you would sell
your movie in your different territories
and everything was very separated
it's still separated now but the issue
is because of piracy
that breaks through all those borders so
it makes it much
more difficult for uh buyers in those
countries to pay you more money
because they know there's also going to
be a pirated version around because it
just will
i mean it just will happen so i think
estimated i think it's one of the
reasons it's more challenging in terms
of distribution
and yes it goes back to what you're
saying with dvds because it was a
physical thing
it was a little harder to pirate i mean
still piracy in physical dvds and
and blu-ray you know but it was harder
because it was a physical tactile object
and a lot of people like to have the
good art and the
you know the good disc with the image on
the desk and it was something people
like to own and have
and now that it's going to the digital
realm it's it's changing it's a
different
thing what about the distribution deals
were they much more in favor of the
filmmaker before or it's always been
sort of a rocky i think they've they've
never been
really in favor of the filmmaker ever
unless you get to a certain point where
you have certain clout or power it's
it's it
but i think the the difference is
because there's like less and less money
coming into the pot so it's still
getting it would still like get siphoned
to this little amount you would get but
because less is pouring in so that
amount is
smaller you know what i mean i think
it's always like distributors
you know they they especially in the
we're talking about the indie side
obviously it's very different
than a big hollywood movie but on the
indie side uh the distributor would take
less of the risk and they don't really
want to spend much money marketing the
movie and they make you pay to deliver
everything to them that's on you to pay
everything and give them everything they
need
so if it sells for them great if it
doesn't sell
really well it's not really that much
skin off their teeth because they're
still going to make a little bit of
money
so that way it becomes more of a
challenge to to the filmmaker
because before there would be a little
bit more of a distribution cost so you
could get maybe a little bit more
marketing from the distributor and it
depends on the distributor
too and like we talked about earlier
it's easy to make
a movie now and because of that
there's a lot more movies now a lot of
the movies aren't good
but but they exist and so
and then you can put a nice piece of
cover art on it and
and stuff and and it looks like a movie
until maybe you watch it
and it's not that good uh but it
clutters the market
and so there's more of that and people
are willing to sell those sometimes like
for nothing and which you know
so it's like all that kind of it's it's
difficult it's always been hard i think
it's just difficult it's kind of like
what's happening with the music industry
for a long time
with the same exact thing when you
started not selling cds and records
anymore as much and then
digital and then it's streaming and then
there's less money coming from streaming
because
people aren't buying the movie on the
cart they're paying for a service and
so it's the same thing that kind of
happened to music
has been happening you know last four or
five years more
with movies so it's the same challenging
market i think
so with making your first feature film
because it was a passion project you had
this great investor
he was in the film did that in some ways
spoil your expectations
because then it was such a wonderful
experience and
whether it was difficult or not it got
made and you had a good relationship
with the person
but then subsequent movies you thought
were going to be
that easy and they weren't i don't know
i'm just assuming
i think every movie has like it's like
going to war and it has its own unique
challenges so it's like it's always
different and the challenges are always
different but it's never easy even
though we had a great experience with
the
with the first film in terms of kendall
and him being an investor
it was still very little money and it
was very grueling
shoot over the course of a year and it
was very tough
i mean physically it was like it was
really brutal uh
thinking how we survived that shoot so
that that was the challenge on that one
and then other ones you you know maybe
you you have more money
it's a little bit of an easier shoot but
then maybe your challenge is because of
your you're dealing with uh sag or
you're dealing with a
union type situation or you're dealing
with a distribution challenge or
something or a location challenge
it's like saying i think it varies from
every movie it's just different
there's but it's always challenging i
think any any indie filmmaking whatever
the genre
i think is is challenging but i mean in
terms of your personal
view on how easy it was going to be did
that one sort of no i don't want to say
spoil it because that sounds too
negative but
did it did it oh did you did you have
rose-colored glasses on
for the longest time thinking that i can
do we can do another one and it's going
to
yes it'll be difficult and i might have
to drive five hours and i have to work
another job and some
that sounds draining to me just hearing
about that
but but in terms of actually getting
investors and making things work
it actually wasn't that easy that one
was like a special
all the stars were aligned or whatever
well that one was really special
uh i'm trying to think
like personally did you did you think
that everything was going to be that
easy
and then well it's weird because it
didn't feel easy it didn't feel easy
okay
it doesn't sound easy so actually kind
of was always hoping it to get
a little easier uh our second film we
also did with that investor
uh and that was ghost of the needle and
um
and that was another great experience
actually production experience was
actually really
really really positive uh on on that
film
had a little bit bigger budget but then
on the flip of it we and we also had a
really good
foreign sales experience uh from that
film but we had a very negative
north american distribution experience
from it
so it started out feeling really really
good and then it became kind of painful
in the end because of distribution even
though like i said overseas it was great
it came out in so many countries and did
really good overseas so
it's always it always feels like you're
you're in a challenge where it's like if
this works out then you have a problem
here
that works out there's a problem there
and uh
you know you just kind of have to roll
with it knowing that there's going to be
these challenges
coming you don't know what they are
sometimes you just plan really really
hard
and try to eliminate all the problems
you possibly can but no
you just know that things are gonna pop
up and then you just have to deal with
them
so as they as they come i think our
are probably our are i mean
echoes the fear is our new one still in
the festivals and it won't come out to
like fall 2019 so i don't know what's
going to happen
that was a great experience making it
was a really great experience making the
movie but in terms of the distribution
process the only one that's been
that kind of went through the full cycle
that was really
uh a great experience for us was was
darker banes
which is a different group of investors
uh tony click
i can't remember the other guy david
cameron's last name
but um but that was a great experience
uh
making uh dark remains and that worked
you know that sold
nicely in the u.s and overseas and it
got a new life
on vod it got picked up uh
later when bod became a more a better
market
it got re-kind of re-released on on the
vod platforms and the streaming and it's
so it's
been that's been probably our most
positive experience going through
distribution
hopefully echoes the fear our new one
we'll see what happens but
uh i mean the film the response from the
audience has been great to the film and
it's been
doing an amazing i mean our biggest
success in terms of festivals because
it's won five best feature awards
it's already done eight festivals um i
think it's gonna be in four or five
uh before it ends it at least before it
ends its festival run and the audience
response has been amazing
so obviously we have high hopes how that
one's gonna
turn out but you know you never know you
just you just get it out there
make the best film you can and then you
work hard to market and release it and
see what happens
would you say you're an optimist
i'm a realist uh but i think you have to
have a little bit of insane optimism to
make an indie film
uh because if you're really a realist
you probably would look at making indie
film and just go no
and you would stop so even though you're
you're realistically you know
what to expect you have to kind of like
have the optimism or the belief or it
kind of boils down to you have to make
it
it's like you you've got the story you
really want to tell
uh my wife and i you know we tell these
stories together
and then eventually there's a point
where it's like we really want to tell
the story so we got to make it happen
and then you just so in that sense it's
optimism yes
because you just have to go we're going
to do it and then you kind of dive in
and do it were you always just were you
always this way or
after making many short films and then
features then you realize like this is
kind of the attitude i need to adopt i
need to be like a
happy realist
[Laughter]
i think it really comes from uh laurent
slow my filmmaking partner i think it
really
comes from her uh she's very much into
like you have to find your own path
and what you're doing creatively not
worry about what other people are doing
not look at other people's success or
lack of success and think about that
you just have to excuse me you have to
follow your path
you know believe in what you believe in
and and then just do it
uh and so i take great inspiration
really
from her because she's very much like
even from going back to the first film
i'm like i really want to make a feature
film i'm not sure how
and she's like well just do it and you
know and she was
she's always been like that in terms of
just finding a way to make it happen
so i think i think probably from her
from her
where does a movie begin for you i think
for me our movie really begins
uh with an idea or the story the key
story element
or or the what if like this is
kind of like a fall um and sometimes
like
uh low will bring you know we'll have an
idea or have a dream
uh and say oh this is really great and
you're like i always jot it down
like i jot down her ideas and and her
dreams and my dreams
when i have an idea or a thought i wake
up from or if i'm daydreaming
and and like oh you know so i kind of
try to write all those
little thoughts down and then eventually
what i find happens is there's some
of those ones that get written down
there's one that kind of keeps chirping
keep like hey and like it like more
ideas
come to it and at a certain point it
reaches critical mass i mean usually
when i have like
10 or 12 pages of ideas relating to a
particular story it kind of reaches the
critical mass where i start going okay
now we're gonna figure out the you know
what this is a real script
you know all these ideas are great and
then figuring out what coalesces into
the script
and then it kind of evolves like i work
with low like
ever you know when i finish the first
draft is very useful because she usually
gets fresh eyes
on it at that point so it's great to get
like a fresh perspective and then
the story grows and then of course as
you are inspired by locations or
or real things you experience and
oftentimes when you as it
progresses like when you start casting
like an
actor can be a huge like influence in
terms of
like oh this person is like changes that
character this could make the movie turn
into this
so all those things kind of and it just
kind of grows so it's fun
so it's my probably my favorite part is
like developing the story
and once that happens once that chirping
is so loud then
how do you bring it to life how do you
know that it's time to start casting
that this is like this is something
worth spending time writing a script on
well it's funny it's like sometimes i i
don't know
until after i've written the script i
mean i've written i was giant bin of
scripts
which sometimes i'll sometimes i'll
finish the first draft of the script
and and i'll feel like okay well that's
good for now i finished this first draft
and there it is and i read it go um
okay this is interesting but not right
now and it'll go in the bin
uh so sometimes like just in the process
of writing the first draft
but then if i finish the first draft and
lo looks at it and i look at it go
there's something here then it might
lead to the second draft the third draft
of the fourth draft
at a certain point the story gets to a
point where you're like yes
this this story's here it's like this is
a
really really good story and we should
we should really make it and at that
point it kind of like
then it kind of moves into the
pre-production phase or like or the
phase of like well how can we actually
make it happen you know
so writing a script is almost like a
safety valve in some sense because
if you see that first draft and you're
like uh
okay i did it i'm not like totally wild
about it imagine you spend
two three years trying to
you know get it made raise money get
distribution all that well that's what
it really boils down to
because it's so hard as an indie
filmmaker
to make a movie it has to be one that
you kind of like
are insane to make because the journey
is gonna be so difficult
so it has to be an idea that can really
stand that test of time
that you could live with it for that
time to not only make it but then
you got to do the festival circuit then
you got to get the distributor and then
once the distributor takes it you got to
work on the marketing of it to help the
distributor out so people know the movie
exists
so it's a very long process it usually
ends up being a three to five year
process when you go through the whole
cycle
so it better it needs to be an idea that
you feel really really really strongly
about
um it's interesting because if i was in
a position probably to snap my fingers
a lot of these other scripting ideas
that i probably would love to see into
fruition if i knew it could be a shorter
cycle
and i think they could actually be
really really good stories it'd be
entertaining and people would enjoy
but the trick is because there's only so
much you can do
you kind of have to pick the one that
kind of leaps to the top like
me you know your mother you know you've
got you got a new me
and that's kind of you know it seems
like there's always one which will float
to the top like that and also it's
realistically it's it's money and budget
it's like i have ideas all the time
i can't make into
a feature film right now because it's
too much money i can't raise it
you go through the process of trying to
shop it to people and get a producer
involved and you go through that process
but you know that on our own we can't do
it it would need someone else
involved which we'd love to do and we
have several of those that we
you know hope hopefully one day will
happen but
that's kind of on a different track than
the ones that you do is just a straight
up indie
filmmaker because that's a little bit
more out of control because you're
dependent
excuse me on some different people
saying yes so it's like you you know
it's like that's not completely in fair
control
was the ones that you know that no
matter what you can do if you set your
mind to it
those kind of move to the top as well
because nothing can stop you as long as
you decide to do it
you know that's the only thing that
would stop you from doing it is the
decision like yes i'm doing this one
how long should it take for you to write
the first draft of a screenplay
like what's your typical turnaround time
for the first drive
well it's interesting because usually
the way i
write a script is i'm usually working on
another
finishing the previous movie
so what i tend to do is
i tend to use a certain amount of my
free time on developing the story and
jotting down ideas
and i can spend a long time jotting down
ideas while i'm working on something
else
and then once it reaches critical mass
and there's enough
ideas jotted down then it's just a
matter of me going
yes i'm going to write that into a
script and finding the time to do it and
i can usually buckle down at that point
after having spent all that time with
the ideas and developing the characters
are there and i know the basic plot
i know the basic set pieces all that's
been you know slowly accumulated over
months and months by doing something
else
the first draft can happen really fast
first draft can be done in in a couple
of weeks
if that's all i'm doing if i'm able to
have a couple weeks straight
all i can do is to sit down and write
you know 10 or 12 hours a day
boom you can do the first draft but the
first draft is the start
of the process the first draft is kind
of like just you taking all those notes
and putting it
into a form where you go ah it's a
script and then at that point
then you can really start i i show it to
lo laurence and and and she looks at it
and we can start the process of like
figuring out what what seems to be
working
what scenes are great well there should
be more scenes like that
this this scene it's like obviously she
won't be mad if i say it
but sometimes she'll so like early on i
would write a script and she would like
i i love the first the first initial
notes on the first draft are fantastic
and sometimes it'll be like giant x's on
a page
like boring you know but it's great
because it basically
you're getting those outside eyes to
know like what's engaging
what's capturing you and then the other
part of it is of course on the drafts
it's like shrinking everything down
everything to its core essence uh so you
don't have any repetition
in terms of scenes repetition in terms
of locations or
characters doing the same thing it kind
of like for me what i've learned over
the years
is you basically like what's the latest
you can get into a scene and the
earliest you can get out
you know it's like how and how can you
make that work and flow
uh and from an editing standpoint and
also low as
a shooter and cinematographer like we
spent a lot of time
um a lot of time with echoes of fear our
last one when we were
doing the different scripts was figuring
out like um
you know how we can make that flow
really nicely whereas the beginning of
the movie we passed through about two
and a half weeks of time
in the first 20 minutes of the movie we
go through about two and a half weeks
and we have a lot of like short scenes
like actually if you clock them there
are like scenes there are 25 seconds
so a lot of it was like figuring out in
the script stage like how to dovetail
the audio
hit the scene have everything still flow
so even though you have all these like
really really short scenes and you're
passing time and you're going
you know in as late as you can and out
as early as you can
but you can't be like disjointed
everything has to flow in terms of the
visual and the edit
and that that first starts with working
that out in the script
and then of course when you get into
post you some you know you push that
even further
but he has to start in the script stage
you know it has to be
thought out that way in the beginning so
you know like these are the moments
in the scene which will bridge us and
visually into the next scene and stuff
so it's exciting to me it's like
that's i mean i love the process of
doing the multiple drafts on
the script and honing it to me like
honing the story is is the most fun
the most daunting is probably like
getting all those initial ideas together
and getting through that first draft
because once you have that then you you
can just play
on all the different versions and just
keep making it better
the same way like when you finish the
movie you keep editing it to make it
better you keep
you know you finish your first version
which is your script
and then like forget the script now we
got this and then you start
letting the movie tell you what it wants
to be and start playing and edit
to like figure out how to even make it
tighter and better
and take it to the next step in the
editing room so then of course
music and sound design that's really the
icing on the kick when you get to get to
that level
you think your experience as an editor
has really helped with the storytelling
i think so because even when i started
um like by the time i was doing
my second or third short so i guess by
the time i was like 12 years old
i was editing at that point i was
shooting super eight uh and believe me
when you shoot
in edit super 8 and you are physically
cutting the film and then having to tape
it back together
you think about why you're editing
because because it's like that is a
process
so you really are editing in your head
because it was difficult you edit in
your head so
as a kid i was like you already started
editing in your head because of the
difficulty of
splicing that super 8 film and putting
it together so i kind of like
learn that and internalize that and then
what you learn is what you start doing
is you start editing in your head before
you even shoot
so before you even shoot anything you're
storyboarding
and you're storyboarding and out from
the edit in your head
and in that in that so it's like you're
editing even from the very beginning of
course that changes
because things on the set and it's very
organic and things may change from your
storyboards and they may change from the
edit in your head when you actually get
into physically
truly editing what you shot but i think
you're just always editing
i think and same with writing and the
same way when you're writing your
editing you're editing the scene
to figure out to make it shorter or
tighter in the words and
do they need to say all those words do
they need to say any words
you know is is it can this just be
expressed by an expression
so it may start out in your first draft
it's a paragraph speech from someone
which turns into maybe three words
so in a way it's like i think editing is
the essence of
telling a story is is editing whether it
be
like editing in your writing or editing
in your head when you're storyboarding
before you shoot or truly the editing
what's called editing when you're
editing your your finished product
so even if i reached a point where i
would be using another editor which i
would not be against at all
in terms of the physical editing i still
think the process
would be a lot of editing would be going
on in my head
uh you know so yeah i think it's just
like a key
element for me is seeing i see it
visually
and that's how i got into making uh
movies to begin with
as opposed to like doing short story
writing or writing novels
as much is that i i i see it in my head
this is how the story comes to me so
in a way even when i'm writing the
script
i'm watching it in my head
sometimes i wish you could just jack a
little cable into your brain
you know it would be pretty awesome
maybe one day that's gonna happen
everyone's gonna be able to do their own
movies because they're gonna be able to
do it but then you have to really think
about it i guess or your
your movie would be pretty jumbled but
uh yeah
like charging an electric car yeah yeah
but
sometimes as the challenge is you see it
in your head in in
on an independent level when you're
fighting with your budget
and it can be very challenging and
frustrating because you have this movie
in your head
and you're trying to get to that it
wasn't until we did echoes of fear
for the first time i felt like i got
something better than what was in my
head
and to me i definitely think it's the
best film we've done lo and i have done
together
and uh and it was such an amazing
feeling to watch the finished movie and
go
that's better than what i edited in my
head
before i did it and made me so happy
because usually the other movies i would
watch
and i was like happy with dark remains
or third movie because i felt like i got
of what was in my head and i was like oh
wow this is an amazing accomplishment i
got eighty percent what i saw in my head
so to actually get something better than
i saw in my head
really made me feel like okay we finally
we finally got it
we probably figured it out so it's
pretty nice well plus you hear so many
filmmakers say it wasn't the movie i
thought i was gonna make
like it it got away from me once we got
in the edit room
it wasn't it was still i'm still happy
with it or whatever
but it wasn't the movie i want you know
because i you have this fantasy
of how we want something to turn out
right and then you're dealing with so
many elements on set
right and things just get away right and
so
that's well the real magic is when you
can like what happened with us with
echoes of fear their own magic is
when the movie takes on a life of its
own and becomes something
better than what was in your head and
that i feel like is when you finally
break through the wall
is when that happens and i think the
really great movies
that's when the magic happens is when it
actually becomes something
beyond it's like you just reach a point
where all the elements come together
and it goes a step beyond what you even
had imagined
and then i feel like then to me that's
like to me it's like the really
rewarding experience
because otherwise you're just chasing
what's in your head and it can become
very frustrating
i mean i guess unless you're david lynch
have 100 million dollars and
by golly you'll get what's in your head
you know because you've got the
resources and money to do it but
you know there's probably 10 directors
in the world who can actually
call you know have the resources to be
able to truly
do no matter what to accomplish their
vision it's very difficult i'm sure even
if you ask some of those
those directors they would probably
maybe who knows
say well it sort of is but you know how
everyone's critical of their own work
right right yeah they hear us something
that we would never
you're right you know sound of a
footstep that they thought
wasn't you know but a lot of people like
i bet you like martin scorsese
doesn't stop editing a movie until
martin scorsese decides
it's he's ready to stop editing oh sure
sure yeah
but this is great about it
yeah it's like when you can reach a
level to have that level of talent
and be able to be recognized so you get
the resources
because people respect your talent and
your vision that's a truly amazing thing
that's true but then there's new
pressure yes of course because then
now if for whatever reason some critic
who's never made a film before
right decides to trash it right and and
tell you how it's all wrong right right
so
yeah true but that's another video
of all the different scripts that you
have and like this bin
yeah i don't know if it's a real binge
oh it's real wow okay that was a
metaphor
i like to have tactile paper so yes it's
a real benefit
okay um have there been any that
you want to make but the budget isn't
there and it wouldn't
do it justice to do it on an indie
budget
yes there's like three that have floated
to the top of that that um i'd very much
like
to do um the process of working that
would involve
some other people uh to make that work
one is a
science fiction uh kind of apocalyptic
creature movie
uh one of them is a very intense
psychological horror movie
uh with the female protagonist or
slash antagonist depending on how you
look at it uh but then another one i
uh that i really wanted to do was um
a comedy horror creature uh
film which i really was really
tried really hard to like crunch numbers
to figure out like how could we
creatively do it
but it still was too much but we
actually came up with a creative way of
telling that story
in a different medium uh so uh
lo laurence came up the idea uh i'd say
well like
i want to do like maybe i could adapt
the script
into like a fun fun text
and then we could have a picture every
three or four pages to make it visual
and keep it fun
uh and then uh and then she came up with
the idea of like well no
it should be like a we should do a
picture per per page of text so like
every page you have text and then you
have a cool picture on the other side
and i'm like oh that's great
so it was a way of us keeping the visual
nature of it
um be able to tell to still have images
uh while also being able to do uh you
know have the text and tell the story
yet not be limited uh by the budget of
like if you were trying to tell it into
a movie and that's
this is an early prototype book of it
called innards
um which it's very early prototype uh we
have
a amazing artist armando norte
who did the uh illustrations for it so
there's 106 illustrations
for the novella so like once again a
picture for every every
every page uh lo is actually doing the
coloring in in a weird way the lighting
on the black and white illustrations
and she also just came up with the other
day it's really exciting she just came
up with the idea
because we were trying to figure out how
to make the text work with the image and
keep it visual as well
and she came up with the great idea that
the text is actually going to be hand
printed as well
to go along so the text even though it's
on the right side it's text it's going
to be hand written and hand drawn
and it's very creative in terms of like
how the
uh how the text is done and that was
always even when it was typed it was
done that way
so like in terms of the words that come
out and the layout and the page and
stuff it's very different
so it's a really unique i'm really
excited about it because it's very
unique
because we call it an illustrated
novella it's not a comic book
but it's definitely not a novella with a
few illustrations so
it's living in this interesting
in-between world between the two
so it's very unique uh but it really it
just suited the story really well
because it was a comedy story
uh the comedy comes from the characters
in the very bizarre situation
uh so with the creature so because it
was common he just really lend itself
to doing it with this fun text style
with the
uh with the images and in a very uh
interesting graphic images to go with it
it really lended itself to be able to
tell it in this way so
that's something we're going to turn to
after echoes of fear our last feature
comes out
uh fall of 2019 hopefully everything
works out on that
uh we're going to start turning our
attention to that low's currently
finishing the coloring and lighting on
it
so yeah so that's that's innards so how
long
how long was the script oh the script
was a full feature script
um trying to remember like how many
script pages i think it was like 98
script pages okay
uh but you know of course it's it's not
the script
i had to like go back to my creative
writing
origins and and you know convert the
script into a story
but the great thing was because of the
illustrations
i could keep the story really simple and
fun in terms of the text part because
the
the illustration of page kind of gives
you a lot of the details that you would
have to do
if you were just writing the story you
did well what does the main character
look like you have to describe it you
did
describe the creature really well and
the location so
basically by having the image of page it
enables you to kind of get more into the
meat and the fun of the story in terms
of the dialogue
in the key events in action you can kind
of jump right to that in the text
because the picture is kind of helping
you along
helping the reader or viewer
along in terms of what what it looks
like visually so that's why it's a fun
really fun marriage and that's where it
comes in a little bit heading into your
comic book realm a little bit
uh but a lot more text in a comic book
where it comes back into novella
world so it's in that nice in in-between
space that we kind of created
we know adaptations are common but how
common is it for a script
to then be turned into a novella or a
novel
whatever you know i think it happens
from time to time a lot of times it
happens because people will do it
um to try to sell the script uh in the
story
which i of course would not be against
if that ended up happening
once the illustrated uh you know enters
the illustrator novella came out if it
helped it turn into a movie great
but our key goal was in doing it to make
it a very
like its own project so if it doesn't if
it leads to the movie
great if it doesn't lead to a movie it's
okay because
it exists in this in its own way you
know in this form that people can enjoy
it
and get the story and once again a way
of
someone experiencing the story uh that
you can't get you can't like hand
someone a script
you know it's like it's like handing
someone who's not an architect the
blueprints of a house
it's not a very satisfying way to
experience a story you know scripts
aren't meant
to be the end result i mean scripts are
always a step like the burpees of a
house to turn into a house to turn into
a movie
so to so this was fun with this is this
basically
you know adapting it in such a way that
it's complete
in and of itself that's really cool it's
very exciting we'll get it done this
year for sure and then we'll figure out
uh like how to get it out there that'll
be a whole new distribution world
because we've never done it you've never
done distribution of
books so i don't know is this so you
don't know so you
we have to learn because it's first time
we've ever done this
i mean i mean our all of our experience
from doing um
movies doesn't really lend itself to
what we're gonna do with this novella so
that'll be something new we'll have to
learn in terms of
distribution and marketing and and you
know what the best way is for
to get it out there to people where did
you actually get the book made
uh it's a beautiful book you want to
hold it up oh yeah absolutely gorgeous
um where did you actually get the once
you had the artist attached and you were
finished with your text
where did you actually get it put
together the book the bounding
well this this is just the prototype of
it uh we wanted to do it
uh lo found a place to have it printed
uh so we could basically have a proof of
concept for ourselves
because uh this was early on before the
text was was handwritten so the text is
just typed
but we just wanted to get a sense and
the images are still black and white
and a lot of them weren't in their
complete stage yet but we just wanted to
get
a sense of like well how would it work
in terms of reading it and experiencing
it
getting your image per page you know and
so how would that feel and how would it
work
and so it was kind of like a proof of
concept for us to be able to hold it in
our hands
and read it and uh you know we made a
lot of changes from this because this
was a great way of us kind of
it's almost like a rough draft or a
first cut of a movie
is a great way to kind of get a layout
of like oh okay
so this is where it's heading and how
can we make it better
and from this we realized that like to
really make it pop
and for the comedy to come through it
was it was important to do the color
and then low actually experimented and
learned how to
do the coloring on it and she's a dp so
it's weird it's like you actually add
lighting once you add color
so in an interesting way you're almost
like adding color and lighting it
and it helped bring out uh the artist of
mondo norde
and it helped really bring his
illustrations out you could really see
the line work he did and everything and
help
like it helped the viewer be able to see
that better
and like see all that detail work they
did on it and
uh and like i said in just um uh
recently
we we learned from doing all that that
she came up with the idea of doing the
text
in a hand-drawn manner to once again
helping with the comedy and the flow of
it
in in complementing the illustrations so
we're very excited how it's going to
turn out
it'd be interesting imagine like it's
such a hit that they want a second one
but they don't want to turn into a movie
they actually like it
in novella form and it becomes like its
own series that's great cool i mean we
every time we do a creative project
we're like we try not to think about
what it's gonna
who knows what's gonna lead to so we try
to be open you know we like finish it
and see where it goes and see what
opportunities it opens up
for whether it's a movie what
opportunity it opens up for another
movie
if it's this you know if it opens up an
opportunity to tell another story this
way i mean it'd be interesting
so i think for us it's like finding the
right avenue
um to tell the story you know what it
lends itself to
you know to tell it did you go to
bookstores the few that are left and try
to see i mean
sorry the few wonderful bookstores that
are left did you go to them and try to
see what other novellas
in the horror section just to get an
idea since this was a new realm for them
well yes we actually
dropped into a amazing um
horror shop called dark delicacies uh
and they are burbank sorry uh yes okay
yes
yes uh and um it was interesting because
uh the proprietor that dell he uh is an
author
himself and he's very aware of
everything that's out there in
publishing especially in the horror
genre realm and it basically there
wasn't there
it's kind of unique there isn't anything
exactly like this
there's some things with an image
um but um it's like every three or four
pages
or it's not balanced the same we did see
like a book that was done there i can't
remember the name of it
later after we kind of done the
prototype and and mapped it out where
they did kind of have an image
and and with with text per page but it
was different it was
it wasn't a novella as much it was
almost like poetry in a way
so so it's like we haven't really seen
anything exactly like this which to us
is exciting
we've heard other people say well that's
not good because it doesn't fall into
like a little niche
like oh it's that type it's this it's
that
but to me it's exciting it's different
remember shel silverstein
like did his thing you know remember
shel silverstein the writer like
oh okay he did kind of like these cool
like poems and
then there would be these drawings and i
mean i'm dating myself i think that's
like a bay area
no i mean he was worldwide i know but so
he kind of
i don't know well when i was a kid like
the poet the poet that really impressed
me
uh in terms of what he did visually was
e cummings
and how he laid out his uh poetry
actually
uh really affected me a lot
actually you know a long time ago did
some poetry and i would kind of like it
was a
i kind of fell into a similar thing
where i would visually kind of move the
words around in a different creative way
which when it got adapted into this
novella that same thing kind of came
through
even though i hadn't done it since i
don't know college i guess
but but the same thing would happen
where like i would bring words up and
words would be big and move things on
the page different and
uh so that's why it's like it's
different even in the tech side of it
it's not just like a normal text where
it's like line nine nine nine nine nine
line paragraph
you know it has its own uh its own uh
rhythm and style in terms of that as
well which will be brought out even more
that's gonna be the text now the text is
gonna be done by hand by low it's going
to
make that even more pronounced so i'm
very excited were you you were a poet in
tennessee
in high school oh god that was good
how was that pretentiously awful
i i didn't have any like-minded people i
filled books
with my poetry uh
which no one has ever no one has ever
seen them except for
uh very good friends and and laurence
obviously lois has seen
has seen some of them but uh but yeah it
was just for me
uh it was it was a way i would let out
creative outlet
uh steam when i couldn't make a movie i
would use that as an outlet
uh that's before i became i would write
scripts so much once i started writing
scripts a lot more
i kind of like kind of stopped doing
that and became my much more just
writing scripts with an outlet
now because of this i'm kind of it's
weird i'm dovetailing back into that a
little bit but uh
well for me it's like the key is
whatever we do i just want it to be
entertaining
because it's like i do this even though
it
it's very personal and it's stories
we're interested in
to me it's like it's also stories that
should interest other people because
it's done for other people to see and
have fun with
uh even when we do the scary
supernatural horror movies they're
for it's fun you know it's scary i mean
it's good to have a it's fun to have a
good scare
and tell a creepy scary suspense horror
story so
everything we do is kind of like focused
on it being entertaining
which is why i get scared to see the
word poetry that's why that poetry does
not exist in little books i hand out
it's just for me
because i don't i don't think it would
those things would be really
entertaining
for someone else it's more like
something i would do creatively but it's
not something designed
for the outside world because i don't
think other people would find it
entertaining
[Laughter]
do you have tips for writing twists and
turns
in a screenplay to really keep that
audience guessing
so that it's a movie where you would
want to see it because you can't figure
it out if you go in cold
you're not going to be able to figure it
out well i think the the best tip on
that
i think is
if the story is coming from your
imagination and
or from what you're inspired by from
real life
or what you're inspired by that's not
from another movie
that will be like a great that would
naturally make it be less predictable
if you're not copying a movie you've
seen
or thinking about well what did other
movies do when they did this
if you're if you're if you're just
bringing the story from imagination
and in in in playing with it that way i
think that's a
that inherently already right from the
beginning will help you
do things that are unpredictable because
you're not basing it on something that's
already been done
i think that the trap you can fall into
is
is like there was a trope
with slasher movies which i love a good
slash movie there's a trope in the 80s
it became a parody and a joke where
people
they would do fake jump scares where
people would open a closet and the cat
would jump out
and it would be like this joke in a
while like how long is this cabin
trapped in this closet
so we could like jump out and scare it
but but it's funny because
even you know alien there's a scene
where the locker gets opened and the cat
jumps out it's a fake jump scare
but it's perfect and alien and it's
handled beautifully
but uh you know it's like but then
everyone's like oh the
the cat jump scare became like this it
became a joke
as it should be because it then it
became used in parodies which is great
using it in a parody but uh so i think
that a lot of it has to do with just not
doing what's been done before
um and you know you can always try to
like
attack that more intellectually if
you're aware of
having seen a bunch of horror movies by
just deliberately making sure you don't
do what's already been done uh or
if you know that's been done you you
make sure if your story naturally has
something similar that you figure out a
way to make sure it goes in a different
direction so you don't
go the direction that usually goes into
which and that's something
we worked um really hard with with uh
echoes of fear there's a a very big turn
in the
in in the end of the second act into the
third act which is very organic to the
story
uh but it but it's a very big turn in
the story
which a lot of people are really
responding to from the festival place
the festival audience is really
responding to that
because once again it takes it in a
direction um
that you're not expecting from how
you're watching the movie and you think
it's
following this path of the way this type
of movie it is but then it goes in a
completely different
way um but once again that came from the
fact that
uh the first part of the movie was
inspired by real events so he drew from
that
and the other stuff came from um true
events and true stories
that we heard about so we incorporated
that into the story and segwayed that in
and that's what made it unique uh
because it wasn't following like a
formula or a particular pattern or
wasn't even obeying the rules of just
falling neatly into a particular
sub-genre it kind of added a sub-genre
as it got to the uh as it got into
heading into the third act
and it's been a great response from that
so i definitely think that it's always
good no matter what story or genre if if
you can
you know think outside the box in terms
of like
just based on how you come up with your
story it'll happen naturally as long as
you're not copying things i think
and then if you feel like your story is
naturally falling into
being too similar to something then you
can work actively against it
you can you can like decide like to
actively like make sure you do the left
turn when everyone else does the right
turn
if you have to if it just happens that
like it feels like it's getting too
close to something you can
intellectually decide to do that
but i think it works best when it's
organic when you're coming up with a
story it kind of works best when it just
the story evolves and naturally those
twists and turns happen because
of the story it's always best if it
could just happen
as you develop the story naturally i
think did you ever catch yourself in the
beginning like you know what
this is way too similar to this one
scene in a bryan de palma movie i can't
do this
this is too much like out did you ever
see because i think it's natural for
writers as well you're going to emulate
those that you're
you're watching your your your reading
and then you realize oh wait i'm
becoming that voice that's not original
i know it's kind of hard to see
especially if it's you're in you're
wrong yeah yeah
i'm trying to think uh i think it was a
trap it was easier to fall into
initially when i was writing um
the script that didn't even get made um
before even before we even did our first
feature
um i feel like i pretty much
actively fight against it i know that
definitely when we come to orchestrating
suspense
uh intention and especially
uh a scare earning that scare
organically and naturally not
using the tropes that
are you overused and doing the same and
that might be an example of kind of like
actively working to turn left instead of
right
you know actively working to not do the
thing that that's usually done
both in terms of sound design in terms
of music in terms of like the build
uh to that moment to like to execute it
differently
what makes a good horror protagonist a
good horror protagonist oh that's an
interesting question
um well i think any protagonist
any genre i think it has to be an
interesting character
it doesn't have to necessarily be a
likable character but there has to be
something about the character
which is fascinating and interesting
that you want to know what they're going
to do
and you're invested in terms of what's
going to happen to them
and i think that's really the key um
you know a lot you know obviously it
is like one of the scripts we talked
about um
the intense psychological horror film
with the with the female
protagonist you know someone could look
at inverse that script and
see her as the antagonist but she's the
main character
it's her story so she's protagonist um
but once again it's like she what she
goes through and she's a very
fascinating character in terms of what
she's experienced and what she's become
and what happens to her and how she
responds to it it
really much pulls you in in the horror
thing in terms of what's going to happen
next
you know how is she going to get out of
that how is she going to solve that
problem what's going to happen to her
oh my gosh what she just did what is
that going to lead to
and i think especially in horror that
has a lot to do with it
is whether you like the protagonist or
or you don't like the protagonist or the
protagonist as an anti-hero
a lot of it has to do with like seeing
what's happening to them
how they respond to it or
what they do which makes the things
happen to them and just kind of seeing
that riddle in terms of what it leads to
like what every step leads to and how
the character responds
so i think the key is it's like the
character
everything the character does needs to
be in character it has to be a response
that that character would have
and of course as the movie moves along
a lot of times your character will
change because the character will have
an
arc but it's natural and organic in
terms of
what's happened to this character their
changes because of
the world that's bombarding them based
on their actions and i think watching
that unfold
especially in terms of horror if there's
suspense and mystery is like
one of the things that really pulls you
in because you're invested because you
want to know what's going to happen
you know with that character is it janet
lee sorry walking up to the
top of the stairs and not knowing
whether the flashlight works
oh right and and not checking and she's
in underwear like i'm taking that from
another video that we
we did someone brought that up like
first of all
yeah yeah somehow film americans think
that women are just always in their
underwear
walking in dark garages or different
things but
exactly in the forest well the funny
thing is it's funny it's like it's
almost the opposite of
what you're asking but there's like this
trope in a horror movie where
where somebody hears something outside
and they go out to investigate and
everyone laughs at people in a horror
film
but the thing is is like but that's what
you would do
in real life because you don't know
you're in a horror film
in real life so if you if you're in bed
and you hear something in your patio
you're going to get up and turn the
light on and probably
see what the noise was it's like
naturally a human thing
but it's it's weird it's become a trope
in horror film because people like
respond and laugh at it but if you
really like think about it
it it's like um it's what you would
naturally do i mean you don't hear
something you don't hear a noise on your
patio and call 9-1-1
and lock yourself in your room if you
don't know what it is we don't know the
noises
so that's a that's an example where it's
tricky because
even though your character would in real
life
do something normal it's like you have
to be really careful that
people don't see it as funny
and it's like it's almost like you have
to fight against
you have to fight against these problems
in a horror film because people will
always be like don't open the door
you know the thing is but of course in
real life you would open the door
so then you have to like in a weird way
it's like oftentimes your protagonist
becomes
hyper-intelligent because you have to
make because you're actively working
against the audience
judging the protagonist from doing
things so in a way you make them like
almost you have to make them like
sometimes like even more
almost like they're they are aware
they're in a horror movie they're doing
things like super self-aware
just but you're only doing it just
because you don't want the audience to
be like why are they doing that
but that can be frustrating because in
real life of course i hear a noise in
the house i'm going to get up and
investigate it
so it's like then that becomes your
challenge as a filmmaker and a writer
how you
do that without making the audience
judge the character even though it's a
perfectly logical thing to do
i mean low laurent a lot of the main
characters
tropes and echoes of fear is inspired by
my wife lo because she's she's totally
fearless she's the one who will hear the
thing on the patio
and immediately will be lights on
throwing open the door and i'll be more
like well wait let me grab something let
me get it back
he's like wait a second what you know
don't rush outside
but uh so actually a lot of the
inspiration came from our character and
echoes of fear from that and making her
a very fearless character
uh and once you establish that as a
character trope
then it stops the problem of it becoming
a laughable thing because it's
coming from the character and when you
realize that the character is
very much someone who takes care of
themselves and isn't spooked out by
things
isn't creeped out by the bumps and the
bumps in the night
uh then you're then once the audience
understands that in a sense about the
character then you can kind of pass
through some of those horror tropes that
would be a problem
kind of halfway answering your question